all right patrick welcome back
thanks for having me yeah so your last
talk
uh was a very interesting one because
you were
thick in the middle of a like a
week-long binge right yeah
yeah i watched it i was very high yes
you were and and it's not i thought
now would be a good time to bring you in
because now you're you're clean and
sober
clean silver at the moment yeah it's
been a few days yeah since i
have been able to get high um and have
you lost your job
that's the number one question
everyone's gonna ask you if you lost
your job i haven't lost my job i need to
you know i need to be responsible and i
need to go to rehab i will wind up in
rehab
soon and then we'll see what happens
with the job
i honestly don't care about the job as
much
as like my life you know
um the depression and the
the uh just the overwhelmingness of this
thing that happens to me that i do
uh is is is so heavy
you know it's so heavy and um there's a
lot of guilt and a lot of shame
you know like the idea of going back to
work and and seeing all
my people is hard right now right fine i
hope you not lost your job because most
jobs you'd be fired by now
uh i think i think the the environment
these days is it's
do they know that you have this problem
yeah they do oh so they kind of work
with you
i mean they they they want to help me
they they love me
uh i love them and you know
it's like it's it's a disease and it's
like a medical disease
and i always do like my best like i
use all my effort to try to stay clean
so i don't know i mean i haven't really
spoken to
any of the managers directly about it
but um they just want me
they want what's best for me and right
now what's best for me is to get help
and uh what happens when the job you
know comes down the road you know
but um it's not i don't think it's as as
common as it used to be in the past to
just fire people
especially if they're honest about
what's going on so
and you certainly were honest yeah i
mean
i was like some of this stuff i said on
there was wow what the hell
um but it's the truth so
what what i mean what do you what do you
think
i mean certainly crack is an addictive
substance
but i like to go to the deeper levels of
things and just to figure out what the
core the stem of it is the cause of it
and is there something
in your self-worth or your or something
that that
maybe is blocking you from like comments
you're intelligent clearly and
and you could you you must see
that this if you do this again it'll
lead to more self-destruction more you
know eventually you'll be homeless
losing your
employ you know losing your income and
everything and you'll
you'll lose your teeth and you'll lose
everything and maybe your life even
right and you're intelligent enough to
know that but
but yet you still repeat this behavior
that's what makes it
super frustrating even more frustrating
that i told i absolutely know
what's going to happen and eventually i
always wind up doing it anyway
you know and that to me that's sort of
like the definition of the disease
of addiction is that knowing what's
going to happen it's one thing to
to be high and you can't stop you can't
stop and then eventually the drugs get
out of your system
and you're you're sober for a few days
and then
the brain that that insists on doing it
again
insist on doing it again even knowing uh
you're going to destroy
everything just i don't care i want that
feeling
you know i don't intelligence and common
sense won't factor in right it doesn't
factor in
does does does like reducing stress or
getting rest or sleep or
anything like that all those things do
help um those will all be sort of like
recovery
type things which i i do like i said i
do that
um the 12 steps you know meditation
exercise like healthy living you know
um you know going after the like goals i
go after all these goals but
i never get there because i'm always on
another relapse and then the relapse is
a destructive
thing and it takes a couple months at
least to even get back to
you know point zero and start again yeah
um so yeah i mean and the thing is is
that i kind of hold on to hope
you know like i hold on to hope that
this might it might work now you know
like it might work now
and uh and god might really like take
away
that broken thing in my brain you know
that like the
the part of my brain that knowing what's
gonna happen does it anyway that that
instead of me having to fight against
that because the fight
never it's never successful it might be
successful like on one
one or two times you know what i'm going
to do it no i'm not going to do it but
eventually
if it fails but my own strength always
fails
so like the idea is that possibly god
will remove it where i don't have to
fight
like a lobotomy yeah like instead of
instead of it coming and i fight it and
i succeed
it doesn't come that's like the idea of
like the 12 steps the part of your brain
that triggers it yeah that gets removed
by something other than myself right
right because like what's the quote like
i can't solve the problem the same brain
that cause a problem can't solve the
problem i think that's an einstein quote
and that's what you know what we try to
do i try to use my my crackhead brain
to solve my crackhead problem yeah and
then the 12 steps kind of
holds up her design to get you to put
into a position where
a god will remove it or remove the
obsession they call it
and uh and i was doing that you know i
was doing that i was making amends on my
ninth step which is another kind of
embarrassing thing i was going around
making you know
sort of like apologizing to people and
having like
really deep sort of like uh
beautiful conversations with people you
know that really want the best for me
and being very honest with them like
like you could imagine and uh you know
just
a couple weeks ago i had what three four
weeks ago i was doing that
and here i am you know so it's hard man
it's uh
very very depressing you know very
depressing
and you've been through rehab before
yeah probably 20 times 20 times
i wish there was some solution to this
problem
yeah i know i talked about like to my
dad and he's he just
i can tell he just feels so bad that i
have to
like i have to have this you know like
like because he says like what you were
saying from
and he says that he knows me better than
anyone like that
i have i'm a great like in all the other
ways
like people love me i do good i try hard
i'm nice
and it's just one thing it's this one
crippling thing that has
now is like just like a lifelong anchor
and like damn it why did i have to get
this you know
yeah because clearly you're you're a
good guy you're intelligent you're
you're
you're never you have all these great
qualities that would have been great
and why why did this have to stick to me
i don't know you know he feels bad
people feel bad people want to help
um you know especially once i do this
you know and i and i'm like sort of in
the aftermath part of it kind of like
right now
like i'm so depressed most of the time i
can't even get off the couch
so i think i may have asked this before
last time
is this a genetic thing or is it a
self-worth
thing i mean self-worth probably i don't
know about genetic i guess it is
genetics you know like uh
um it definitely runs in my family not
my parents but my
you know brothers and cousins um
yeah self-worth my self-worth is zero
and i was thinking about this recently
talking to talking to somebody too
like even in between you know like i'll
be clean doing good
doing 12 steps doing my life going to
work enjoy and i'm always
i'm always happy i'm always happy like
i'm always like like in the moment like
content but my self-worth is very low
yeah
i i go to a gym every morning i do it
every day of the year and this morning i
was there
early in the morning it's raining i have
to do it outdoors because of covet and
it's poor it's pouring rain and i'm
working out in the rain
with you know it's freezing cold and
there's a bunch of other people doing it
and
i was joking with somebody that the only
the reason these people are so dedicated
is most i would bet you half of them
have have addiction issues and they've
replaced that addiction with
exercise i was at the gym all the time
and uh
i haven't been since covert originally
hit but uh yeah
in the gym all the time like anything
anything i do i do it addictively
anything you know like i try and that's
the thing that's the thing that i have
is that
trying to use my brain to fix all the
problems so as soon as i'm clean
that's one thing that will happen like
i'll go to rehab or i'll get i'll get
like some time clean where it's like
okay
i'm gonna be and i switch over and the
depression lifts and all of a sudden i'm
excited again about being clean
but the chance not to be stuck and i'll
go on like that
and everything i do i'll do addictively
and i'll try to cram 30 hours into a
24-hour day
and i'll feel great and everything's
like on schedule and like super
anal like super like you know overboard
obsessive like with
everything that i'm doing um trying to
be perfect
trying to be perfect um
i don't know maybe maybe i get burned
out on it i don't know dude
are you a perfectionist yes you're very
demanding on yourself yes oh gosh
yeah i'm sure there's there's something
there very much so i can't
like to the even to the point of like
one thing one thing i have is that i
want everybody to love me like
i think i mentioned that last video i'm
always uh trying to make people laugh
like i'm always making funny comments
and i'm like i'll say something and i'll
be
it'll be the idea that like maybe like i
said something stupid
will haunt me like for the rest of the
day right like one stupid thing that
nobody cares about nobody would even
remember
i'm like stewing in it like oh my god i
think you said you want everyone to love
you because you don't love yourself yeah
yeah to think i'm brilliant and think of
you know i think i'm great
yeah and a lot of people do think that
you know no i i think acceptance and
forgiveness of ourselves most
importantly is is probably
at the core of a lot of these yeah
problems you see on my channel yeah like
this
yeah yeah true and this is because an
outsider would say
you're a great guy you're handsome
you're intelligent you seem like
great in every way yeah just love
yourself don't don't feel the need to be
perfect yeah that's
that's what someone would say watching
you but
like that same person might say yeah and
just uh just stop using drugs
like okay well thanks for that yeah i
mean that would work
that would be that would be you know
like that would be a good plan
um yeah i i think loving ourselves is is
the biggest challenge we all have
yeah every every one of us it's hard for
me to even imagine that to love myself
you know it's hard to even imagine it's
hard right now for me to imagine ever
doing that
and and were you that way since since i
think i think it's gotten more no
i think it's i think it's i think it's
evolved and grown
yeah incrementally over the years as i
continue
to not get through this because i've
been like trying like i've been going
doing like going to rehab and
setting my life up completely around the
goal of
overcoming this since i was 25 i'm 42.
so when i'm 25 it's like okay great
okay now i'm clean maybe i'm clean a
year uh i
started believing in god all that was
exciting you know i'm 25 i had the whole
my whole life in front of me that i got
over this crack issue
right and then no and then okay now i'm
26. you know whatever
like and the older you get the more
pressure there is and then no and the
time
right and at some point along the way
like i get to go to school and like
you know maybe that's a sign of like you
know kind of getting getting over the
hump
and then no you know and then moving
home and starting to work
and you know and then no and and just
you know and i work with all these great
people and just i know that none of them
do anything like this and sometimes i'll
be at work six months
clean not even thinking all of a sudden
i'll just be in the bathroom and just
like
oh my god i can't believe that i do this
that i did this six months ago no but
it takes many different forms yours
happens to be a crack
addiction but there are others who have
eating sure
disorders or gambling or laziness or
eating too low with their relationships
lives
i'm sure everybody has something my i
guess i
think i feel like i focus on mine
because i'm me and because it's so crazy
and you're a perfectionist
and yeah but but it's so crazy it's so
you know
it's out there you know it's it's way
out there
and do you i mean do you think it was
something
about the way you were raised or your
childhood or do you think i'm trying to
keep going i keep trying to figure out
what the what the truth
is yeah i mean there was that thing with
the molestation i guess
uh that i never really thought about um
but i always had a thing with sex like i
talked about before
um i don't know
you know a lot of it i do know that a
lot of like my behavior like when i'm
when i'm using is something of a
something of a
like a chase or a trying to recapture
the very beginning like when i first
discovered all this
and uh and i want to be like that
you know like like like the idea of it
back then was just
so like intriguing and so like i wanted
to do it so bad
and it was more like i don't know it was
it was more out there back then there
was no internet there's no cell phones
back then so everything was kind of like
on the streets you know you drive on the
streets and everything's right there
and so have you talked to a therapist
about this off and on over the years i
have
i've had great experiences with
therapists but not obviously nothing
that
you know the more of these the more of
these interviews i do
we were talking about this before the
cameras started the more
the more i do these the more i'm
starting to
suspect or fear that we never really
change
yeah we might improve a little bit
incrementally
if we really work hard at it and have a
lot of courage and forgive ourselves and
all the
things that we've mentioned but we never
really just all of a sudden become
perfectly healthy and
functionally functional i think people
do more than maybe you see
down here now that i'm thinking about a
little more you know i go to aa meetings
and na meetings and
there's definitely people there that are
even though maybe i didn't know them
before you could just tell like the way
they are they've straightened their
lives out
they're just different people yeah
they're different people all together
the way
the way they look at the world is
different yeah that i think that's
what's needed
yeah and i feel like maybe i've tasted
that a little bit here and there
you know like it's like it's like
looking at the world from the angle of
okay
god is real first of all so like
whatever happens i don't have to even
worry about it like all this that i have
i could accept it and not even worry
about it because god is real
and then going about life with the
number one priority being to help
somebody else there's people that like
do that as a
as a as a practice as a way as a way of
life
and that's sort of the goal of that
those programs is
to to build that way of life to do
little things day by day
uh and do sort of like work on like
going back into your own life and seeing
more and some of the stuff that came up
through some writing and then you're
able to like launch out
and and be out there helping other
people like me and i know dudes like
this that
that are very like very much like that
they're very like uh
uh attractive you know um guys those are
like the guys that i want to be like
yeah
i have guys like that in my life and i i
know that people do change
yeah i've known them in my life yeah
people that have really made a huge
transformation
yeah but it has to be sort of like along
those lines like
i don't i think you might be right like
people like me
we don't just change ourselves like it
doesn't i mean if we don't do anything
it's nothing's gonna change
you know for me even doing a lot seems
like nothing
and for some people it's religion and
other people's yeah for other people
it's it's like exercise or something
extreme
yeah but to me i think that helping
others peace is is a huge part of it
yeah like not living for myself because
at the core this thing is very selfish
like like the drug addiction is a
selfish thing
it just is and uh
so like the antidote to selfishness is
to like
not think of yourself at all to be like
what can i do for the next person how
can i help this person
you know so and if that's the case you
think
do you think it's courage to not be
selfish or to to do things that you've
never done before or something like that
to me courage is a big part of all this
i mean courage
i think courage comes along the way
because it's not it's not the
determination and discipline a little
bit a little bit
of discipline not so much discipline not
to use but discipline to
do the right thing discipline to you
know get up in the morning and like
sort of start the day thinking a lot
thinking about it in those sort of in
that sort of way
what can i do today how can i help
somebody else today yeah certainly
discipline support um
yeah and just to to be committed to that
um and i mean the times i've had i've
had a few like
uh opportunities to help people like
like even directly through sponsoring in
the 12 steps or that sort of thing or
just even talking about it whenever i
whenever i do i feel better like
whenever i do i feel like i'm
like i feel great like it's a good
feeling and where i wasn't even seeking
that feeling i was just trying to help
the other person so
that's the thing but what but but there
is al always the big question like why
isn't it sticking
like why is it that's where that's where
i'm suspicious that maybe courage is the
answer
whereas if you started doing some
helping and maybe dug
in deeper and even helped further or on
a deeper level
really committed to it yeah then your
self-perception would change so
it could be so so deeply so profoundly
that that
you would no longer
feel any shame that the shame would
disappear it will i believe that it
would
be shameless oh yeah crippling
i mean if you were to consistently do
things
that would make it impossible for you to
see yourself as anything other than
altruistic and kind and a good person
where you're helping others relentlessly
wouldn't that impact your self-worth
significantly yeah i i think that's true
um maybe i just haven't gotten deep
enough into it yet you know maybe like
if uh i could get past six months nine
months without a relapse happening and
continue on the path
that i've been on you know because
whether it's
drug addiction or sex work or or
whatever
whatever your advice is it creates shame
yes
and if you can do something that really
erases that shame and usually helping
another is a
great way to do that what better way
right right then all of a sudden your
shame disappears
and without the shame then then that
that was your number one
factor in why you're doing this
self-destructive stuff in the first
place
so you're thinking rehab now yeah that's
why
that's what i should do that's what you
know that's the the
clear thing that i should do uh i have
i'm considering going to the east coast
where i have some friends
or possibly here i haven't decided where
and just try again i guess what my mom
says just try again
what can you do except try again and uh
it's like the other option
you know i don't know would be like uh
die
i get homeless um
never really been homeless i don't know
if i could hang on that and uh
yeah i think the helping thing is
probably something that gets back to
that yeah i mean it's just it's
it's it's pitiful like this whole
thing's just pitiful
um i'm getting old
i don't really care yeah i was talking
to my dad about this too like i don't
really uh
care like like prestige or position or
money
has never really been like the motivate
like the driving factor for me to be
happy or content like i've been in
long-term rehab situations where i had
like
pretty much no money and i was totally
happy i was just as happy as i'll be
here working
you know um every any situation that i
ever mean
if i'm clean and and being productive
that i'm content
and i and uh so i don't know
you know i don't know like like i
mentioned teen challenge last time where
teen challenge where i had the longest
you know the most probably
highest percentage of days clean in us
in a stretch
but a lot of that was because i was
living there you like live there and
help
work there with the students and but you
were helping but maybe that's what
maybe maybe i'm just not cut out for it
maybe i need to go somewhere like that
and just stay for the rest of my life
and
people do that like i want to be the end
of the world and i would have i would be
helping people i'd probably be happy
probably wouldn't have any money but who
cares you know yeah
the older i get the more i think that
there are there are alternative
paths in life that can lead to happiness
and fulfillment yeah
than what than what society says that
you're supposed to do yeah
yeah and uh and i'll probably be able to
be very very helpful to people
i'm sure you can like if i get my act
together
no i i i can totally see
you doing great things for yourself and
for others
yeah very clearly yeah
but you'll need to get out of this
quicksand that you're in here yeah
yeah now's the time
absolutely well patrick i wish you the
best of luck with whatever you do
thanks mark and uh maybe we'll do this
again one day
yeah let's do it again you know down the
road and see the difference
you know there's there's definitely a
difference you'll see a difference
between me
i'm not high compared to last time but
if you catch me
three months clean you'll see the
difference between this and that for
sure
i'd love to see it again that'd be great
all right all right
thank you very much
you